what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Trace Meyer is a
true Bitcoin OG he was buying Bitcoin in
2011 and is the hot ler of last resort
in this conversation we discussed the
early days of Bitcoin how tres built his
initial conviction where the asset is
today would trace thinks are the most
important things to watch and where we
are headed next this is a can't-miss
episode so I highly recommend listening
school want to know who has the best URL
crypto comm that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother and mass adoption that's
why we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mind it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mine
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin micom tell them pomp Sencha
and thank me later as many of you know
crypto investors store their digital
assets on exchanges or in cold storage
for long-term safekeeping however this
strategy doesn't help them grow their
investment holdings or build overall
wealth with the new block by interest
account users can now securely store
their Bitcoin or Ethernet block five and
receive six percent annual interest paid
monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block feiyr.com slash pop
again that's block five comm slash pop
to sign up and start earning crypto
today you follow Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it
they've got more than ten million other
traders that love it too and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their hundred thousand
dollar virtual trading feature but if
you're more experienced you can create
custom technical charts and use eToro
Social Feeds to inform your trading
decisions they've got transparent fees
and so you never miss out they also have
an easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at btro calm again that's eToro comm get
VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto markets
today Anthony Pompano is a partner at
Morgan Creek Digital all opinions
expressed by palm or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp has a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I'm here with
probably one of the people I have both
look forward to having you guys listen
to mr. trace Meyer thanks so much for
doing this yeah thanks for having me
this is gonna be fun so trace and I
talked to Todd and he's got a bunch of
really powerful ideas and just been
around the Bitcoin space for a long time
so let's start from day one what were
you doing before you ever heard of
Bitcoin yeah so I had written a paper on
money and currency in American law in
law school so a very deep like an
academic paper so I got a good
philosophical foundation
I started reading Mises and rothbard and
dr. Viera you know all this type of
stuff so I got a good foundation in
Austrian economics then I took a course
in Mises Academy on network effects in
the digital age this was before Bitcoin
even came out you know so I mean people
are like oh people just got lucky
like my in Bitcoin it's like nah man no
you didn't just get lucky like buying
Bitcoin and he definitely didn't get
lucky hobbling it yeah right why I
always say that there's some people who
got lucky in the sense that they were
you know early in video gaming or they
were doing nefarious things like and
they were just looking for a currency
right and then they usually forgot they
had it and then it end up being where
they spent it really spent it you
specifically were focused on money you
saw it
I will get into kind of how you saw it
and what you did but you not only have
held but you've continued to Baja right
yeah and so the conviction level is off
the charts right via for me I mean like
I coined the term on on Pierce podcast
noted Hodler of last resort yeah so
alright so you're studying kind of money
economics finance etc and then when do
you first lay around the gold what I've
been in digital currency in the mid-90s
you know in high school and mid late 90s
and played with played around with
eagled we've played around with
encryption played around with Napster
and Kazaa I'm wire and like all so I
mean like this is confluence of all
these things I developed the human
capital you know the most important
thing you can do is invest in yourself
like what's the return gonna be on that
like education sikita opportunity and a
lot of people you know they they just
don't invest in themselves they don't
have that time preference they don't
have the curiosity and so you know luck
is when that preparation meets
opportunity and so I had done that you
know I instead of dinking around like
watching TV like I was reading Mises
like I mean I didn't get lucky like
people in this in in especially having
the conviction to Hottel you know like I
didn't get shaked out by like Jihan and
his be cash
thing I mean I just swiped a bunch of
his bitcoins yep like lots of them
yep and so you know this is this is how
this game is played we're at war taking
territory on the Bitcoin blockchain
measured in satoshis mm-hmm and so as
you were doing the self-study really
educating yourself baltimore technology
and then on money and finance there was
a point in time where you were one of
the probably more prominent voices
around gold right maybe talk a little
bit about what you were doing there and
kind of what the thesis was yeah so
because I'd written that page I'd always
been interested in the money and then I
like learn the feel of the philosophy
behind sound money and and its role in
politics and political philosophy and
everything and in that whole time I mean
I was trading I was trading you know I I
straighten stocks and in high school and
and I was trading derivatives in college
in law school you know I'm trading
futures and I'm trading like puts and
calls and I mean freaking crush it on
the Google IPO because I bought calls
and then it like did the s-curve and I
like layered in on the calls and so like
those I mean I made like 120 acts on my
Google investment in six weeks you know
because I played the derivatives right
yep and and I really liked the
derivatives because you can you can like
with laser precision like hedge out your
different risk so you know I I'm very
sophisticated in a lot of the stuff and
then then I ran into gatah
and in dr. Viera went and had breakfast
with them at the gatah conference in DC
and you know if you're not familiar with
the gold price suppression scheme and
the work of gado-gado org the gold
antitrust action committee you just
don't understand how the world works
like I mean you just don't you just
don't waste the website gat gat a ga ta
org and you know because the central
bank's a they hold gold in the vault and
go down on loan as the same line-item
they're reporting cash accounts
receivable is the same thing we're
talking about something that they can't
print they only have a half to a third
of the physical gold they claim to have
that would based on forensic accounting
oh they're bad at their financial
statements and this was in the mid 2000s
which probably gotten worse in it yeah
it's gotten worse some central banks are
starting to buy more gold now but
I mean Gold's the locus of the financial
world and I mean like and they want it
it's very odd if you own a lot of
something why run a cartel to suppress
the price and it's because the price of
a portfolio asset is irrelevant compared
to your power to issue what we use as
currency yep and so the you know they're
propping up their Fiat paper franchises
and it I mean it's just so so that whole
area was was huge you know and and so
I'd started run to gold in 2008 rule is
that run to gold calm just a blog I'd
write about monetary and economic stuff
and then the first week of 2009 I wished
my book the great credit contraction
asserted that it had started so we'd
spend five hundred years going from
commodity money and fractional reserve
banking a commodity money and folders
were banking to fractional reserve
banking and fiat currencies over a great
credit expansion five hundred years and
you know now it's kind of reached a
zenith an economic law it's gonna come
back down capital burrowed down the
liquidity pyramid into safer more liquid
assets which is exactly what we saw
happen you know and part of the reason
why I think interest rates are where
they're at this is where I differ with
Peter chef you know hyperinflation it's
like no no capital is gonna burrow into
Treasuries because those are safe and
liquid and then they'll eventually
evaporate into nothing through
hyperinflation but you know that's gonna
be down the road and only when the
capital get moves from them to something
lower in the pyramid which will be gold
and silver at the time when I've
published a book or increasingly it
looks like it's going to become pick
coin and so you know bitcoin was a very
natural fit into my thesis on the great
credit contraction coincidentally you
know I give an example in the book where
somebody's like extinguishing a dad or a
trade and using silver coin to buy pizza
we have the thing that speeds the
transaction which happened with someone
in my in my in my city I grew up in and
so that's gonna pull of it you know just
find out all these things oh yeah you
know it's just by coincidence yeah so
anyways I published that book the same
week Bitcoin came out so the great
credit contraction has started we had
all the craziness of Oh 809 and then I
also started my podcast that same week
2009 run to go to podcasts early yeah
early to the podcast yeah pretty much
everything right and yeah so that's kind
of where it's at so then you know I let
Bitcoin I learned about it and then and
then you know of course like let it
germinate a little bit more and then
January of 2011 you know at about a
quarter that's when I started first
publicly talking about it and and what's
the first pop popular blogger you know
someone had millions of people the
millions of page views and stuff like
that first person that would really talk
about it I mean otherwise is very
obscure and then Roger bear he came in
started talking about a couple months
later and then you know everything's
kind of off and runs in there to
describe how early you are if you asked
safe teen who wrote the Bitcoin standard
you are where he learned about Bitcoin
first right it just people who were
interested in Austrian economics gold
etc they were learning from you when you
were writing but yeah so and I
specifically targeted them you know cuz
I was thinking about this it's like okay
if this really plays out and we have
this well transfer the life so it's the
world's never seen which is gonna be
huge once in a species opportunity
triple entry bookkeeping sound is
hardest money who do I want to have be
the benefits of that you know be be the
benefits of that wealth transfer and I'm
like well I like the gold bugs because
they should understand money and the
libertarians because they're just crazy
and and what would the world look like
if a bunch of libertarians were altra
rich crazy you're like that's gonna
change the political constitution of the
makeup of the world so those are the two
niches that I went out and started
targeting and sure enough you know
latch onto it some of them didn't it was
interesting you know like Lew Rockwell
he just was not interested in Bitcoin at
all Peter Schiff you know bitcoins
bitcoins eight dollars and we're a we're
an investment conference in Palm Springs
we have all the interview equipment out
because I just finished it with the
future money trends guys Peter Schiff
walks by a new from Ron Paul they're
like we start having a conversation and
they're like hey why don't we why don't
we put this on like record and put it up
on YouTube and Peter's just like you
know weasel in his way out of it and he
finally makes the same and he's like no
I don't want to because you'll make me
look stupid mm-hmm it's like oh so it's
not about the audience and what's best
for them it's about whether you're gonna
keep making peas off of him right I lost
a little bit of respect for him because
for the most part I mean I've given all
my work away for free I mean I charge
for my book when it first came out but
now it's free I give everything away for
free I don't have any ads and my podcast
or anything like that it's like you know
I I like to think of myself as kind of
the clarion call warning people you know
and and that that was good for the first
decade bitcoins out there it's not going
away not going anywhere instant so now
we get to be a little bit more
competitive yeah in this next decade
well so one of the things that you've
told me previously that fascinates me is
when you first started writing about it
it was somewhat from a bent of like oh
we may have missed this right even
though it was still what $1 $5 I don't
know what the price was but it had gone
from you know three tenths of a penny to
whatever already but it's 30 bucks crash
to $2 and there was a sense that early
in the community of like oh you know we
all just missed this huge run from a
penny to $30 yeah I mean I I didn't not
that we missed it it's just we missed
that particular run
because you know we're going to have
these massive volatility these massive
types of runs because man people are
just it's like the dog on LSD like
chasing the rabbit yeah I mean and and
there's no punch protection team to like
moderate these prices and and if the
point protection gene tries to they're
gonna get wrecked yeah you think they
can't deliver fake bitcoins yep so like
the thing that the traditional market
stabilized is not available here and
therefore you get the volatility but
we've been trained I think uneducated
that the volatility is bad and that the
markets are bad when they're hyper
volatile but actually it's a very
natural thing ya know it's actually a
wonderful process of price discovery and
and allocating the the the different
resources and Mises even writes about
this in human action the evenly rotating
economy and just ahead so fools iron to
try and try and make work so you know
people who want to seek safety and
security and all this stuff like nope
we're going in we're sailing into a new
world
yeah where we're going to have a much
more volatile more volatility because we
can't moderate the prices plunge
protection team's not gonna be able to
handle it where are they gonna get the
resources what walk me through what the
thesis on Bitcoin is today right in
terms of so we've had a decade is not
going anywhere everything you've said so
far you know I pretty much agree with
how do you look at Bitcoin given the
rest of the macroeconomy
some of the issues that we're seeing as
warning signs in the legacy system and
then where that asset is today and how
it kind of can play out over the next
few years yeah I mean we're building the
we're building the replacement bitcoins
the lifeboat the current system is
burning like how long you're gonna stay
on it the losses are gonna have to you
realize by somebody for real like you
know there's no way to avoid the final
crack-up boom and we have so much that's
been hypothecated and re-evaluated
they're they're they're real and
productive assets in the economy and the
combined like productive ability of the
economy just doesn't justify all the
debt that's out there now we got a
negative yielding debt
so like the current system is totally
food barred and Bitcoin looks to be the
solution why
you know Plan B with his modeling
Bitcoin scarcity and then the
cointegration that helps prove that
model you know I think that's very
important so now we're like if you're
managing large amounts of assets you
have like you're totally negligent if
you aren't seriously considering Bitcoin
in part of the portfolio so I started
saying this probably last year's a 2018
where it was more so when my partners
and I go in to go talk to these
institutions there's a tipping point
right and I wasn't just so much claiming
like we're at the tipping point as much
as we were getting close to the tipping
point of if Bitcoin has data that shows
as a non-correlated asymmetric asset and
we understand how in putting that into a
portfolio with modern portfolio theory
it has a positive impact on the
portfolio and you're aware of that and
you don't do it there is an element of
you're actually violating your fiducia
mindin to do it right well that's where
the questions to come right is why for
real like why didn't you do it
why'd you why'd you miss out on this
exactly and I think at first you know
mark usko my partner who's been in the
asset major business 25 30 years now
saying something like that is very kind
of hyperbole right and and just was a
little uncomfortable and then I started
thinking more about it now he's like no
actually there's a lot of validity in
that because the data is the data right
what it promises to do is exactly what
ya institutional investors are supposed
to be look I'm gonna look at Bitcoin
Sharpe ratio look at like what did you
its uncorrelated look at Plan B's work
you know where where you're able to
model out with 99.5% correlation the
Bitcoin price based on stock to flow in
days and then you're able to prove that
with cointegration so walk us through
stock to flow what is it and kind of how
that work the work you did and then yeah
he's doing yeah so I mean because I came
out of gold you know and in trying to
value gold especially with all the
central bank interference I honed in on
stock to flow very early and you know I
think they're even tweets were where I
put out about Bitcoin stock to flown
like 2014 and 2015 and you know and so
then sayfudine when I wrote the Bitcoin
Stan
was just totally the book I would write
if I weren't lazy he did an excellent
job of that book and and I just can't
praise him enough on that part of the
reason I did a legendary series with him
on my Bitcoin dollar podcast five
episodes highly recommend to those along
with the series I did with Adam back and
so you know that we got that and then
what was it like six months ago or
something Plan B came out with this and
Plan B somebody on Twitter
yeah anonymous guy on Twitter supposedly
works at a qualm fund or something but
he took what I found intuitively when
looking at the Bitcoin thesis you know
because I also came up with the Seven
Network effects a Bitcoin speculation
merchants consumers miners or security
developers I put in there like
accountants attorneys regulators
financialization things like back to
ledger ax futures options and then world
reserve settlement currency so that's
the destiny or the potential destiny and
it's like what you know and in their
entire industries and then companies
within those industries within each of
those network effects and they all
exponentially reinforce each other the
network effects too you know because
I've taken that Mises Academy course on
network effects like before Bitcoin even
came out and and network effects in the
digital age I was like oh my gosh like
bitcoins gonna have all these network
effects and blah blah blah so I mean I
just really honed in on Bitcoin I'm like
man this could be a solution to the
great credit contraction like where do
you run for protection of hearsay
hundred of living because it's gonna be
much more about just protecting yep the
capital you've got or or think you've
got because a huge amount of that what
quiddity pyramid has to evaporate into
nothing because it never existed in the
first place yeah we've talked to own
with that nauseam at this point of the
podcast about how inflation creates
wealth inequality gap how it eats away
at the actual wealth somebody has it
steals the wealth it inflates assets it
enriches the elite etc in it and most
importantly I'd say it distorts it's a
form of economic censorship and what
this gold price suppression scheme has
done is its effectively censored
interest rates which are a vital
mechanism to allocate resources in the
economy and overtime and so like if
Bitcoin really is censorship resistant
it's going to be able to withstand
economic
censorship which i think is going when
and when that happens now we no longer
have a centrally planned global economy
using fiat currencies and fractional
reserve banking to carry out political
means deciding who gets different
capital and who doesn't right and so all
of this you know all this I intuitively
felt all of this and even could
articulate it and you go back and look
at some of my early interviews and stuff
you know I did a pretty good job with it
you know four six seven eight years ago
but you know it was still very intuitive
for me but Plan B has just logically
laid out and done a lot of the math on
this stock to flow and it's like almost
scary hi it's free it's not just scary
it's it's so scary that he said you
could go back and use only the data up
through like mid 2011 and still come out
with the same model mm-hmm so it's been
sitting there in for everybody to
discover right and then like black
Scholes I was listening to one of his
podcasts and he's talking about black
Scholes the guys it was out there
publicly available for a decade before
like portfolio managers decided to start
using it mm-hmm and so it was
exploitable for that whole time usually
the same things happened with Bitcoin so
I think the first decade was you know
we're we're all still kind of stumbling
in the fog like trying to figure out
what to do with this thing you know and
I was you know waving a hot or last
resort I just buy this stuff and hold it
and hold your own keys and don't put
them on Mount GOx and blah blah I didn't
lose a single Satoshi oh my gosh like
because I'm just not what I'm gonna do
and proof of keys right proof of keys
calm like it's coming January third you
imagine global coordinated bank run on
an asset that strictly limited an amount
that everybody can verify with a full
note that they can run on a Raspberry Pi
it's crazy like and we're gonna do this
every year
this proof of keys mmm you know and
these banks they say you have a problem
in the repo market right now his wife
all right so on the stock the flow stuff
the accuracy is really really scary but
dashana and it's got cooked and it's
been proven on the cointegration so
there's a explain what that means so so
okay it's highly correlated so what it
could be a
correlation you know and and we've seen
all different types of charts like you
know the butterfly flaps its wing in
Tokyo and you have an earthquake in
California and and it happened at the
same time and yep and therefore it's
correlated right three times you happen
three times therefore it's correlate we
got ourselves a trend so you can have
spurious correlations so so in in
econometrics and I don't really agree
you know I I'm much more like a
fundamental in terms of like the
Austrian economic theory but I think
there's a lot that we can learn from the
math and and I and I don't think we
should grown away from the math if it's
hard to do so you know I like to first
make sense of it in terms of the the
philosophy and the logical argument and
then I like to apply the best tools I
can you know whether that's Mayer
multiple or the you know econometrics or
whatever anyways so they looked at the
cointegration and they and and tried to
falsify the hypothesis to say as a
spurious correlation and actually it's
cointegrated so that means that it's not
a spurious correlation but it actually
is this way so now now like portfolio
managers are gonna have to look at this
and be like oh my gosh like so we're
looking at a six-figure Bitcoin price in
2021 yeah because the stock the flow is
gonna change in the number of days yep
and and we know we know what the stock
to flow is gonna be because the
difficulty adjustment algorithm and we
know how many days are gonna be and
those are the only variables that are
determining our price yeah well in the
thing that's interesting to me is that's
all with the value right so the way that
I think of the value or price right
won't mean value is objective yeah value
meaning that is what if without human
excess and greed right this is where the
price is gonna go what I think you see
those is in the euphoria when you go
from ten to twenty thousand dollar price
point that's your mayor multiple right
exactly so explain explain what the
mayor multiples yeah so first I didn't
coin it I'm no really I'm not that way
no but okay press press and push
probably an investor's podcast like
coined it okay and and then everybody's
like Oh more math
winters love to do math right we got
some skills there so so basically I ran
into the problem that I figured was you
know with the gold pressure suppression
scheme is if they're economically
censoring the the pricing mechanism like
how am I going to determine whether
something's actually a good value or not
mm-hmm how many enter do man cannot a
calculation cuz they're like screwing
with the thing that I'm using as a unit
of account and then it's like oh I'll
just like I'll put it in the numerator
and the Dominator and then I'll cancel
it out so I take the current price and
the 200 a moving average and that gives
me and then I get to cancel out the
dollar signs right and actually did an
interview with anthem Blanchard because
his father helped get gold legalized and
and we know Blanche are not in Blanchard
& Company founded it but and we talked
about this you know it's kind of a
secret decoder ring where you can cancel
out the dollar sign in the equation and
so that that gives me a relative price
you know so if we have ten thousand
dollar Bitcoin today and the two hundred
a moving average is 8200 then we have
like a 1.2 May or multiple well you can
take that that relative price and you
can look at it over time and look at
standard deviations and so you me like
okay like if it's over two point seven
then it's expensive relative right and
if it's under like point six or 0.7 or
point eight really then it's cheap and
you know and in between is what and
in-betweens kind of fairly valued you
know and you know and and I like to look
at like one two and three standard
deviations on both sides and create
bands and and so you know good example
of practically applying this because you
know I've started trading the
derivatives so in December of 2018
you know bitcoins that what four
thousand dollars probably lower than
that yes and in volatility was kind of
low ball is low and so on ledger X guess
what I did what I bought 77 June 2025 K
calls at between eleven hundred and
fifteen hundred dollars apiece
skirts girl want to know who has the
best URL crypto calm that's right crypto
calm their crypto platform with one goal
mother masa
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pomp sense you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm tell
them pump sent you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block v
comm / pump again block v comm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today wait wait hold on you
but seventy-seven calls for June 2020 so
a bit a year and a half out 18 months
out yep at by five thousand dollars five
five K strikes yep and I pay it between
eleven hundred fifteen hundred premium
how's that gonna turn out well they're
already $5,500 in the money and I still
got like eight months left yep yeah yeah
because I was like oh you know like oh
this is gonna be after the happening and
so basically I'm up 3.7 X in Bitcoin
based on the capital that I deployed
mm-hmm on top of the price appreciation
of Bitcoin yeah yeah yeah majored in
Bitcoin the these option the the options
are now worth three point seven acts in
Bitcoin of what I paid for so it so I'm
actually generating significant alpha
versus just holding Bitcoin itself yep
right and in and pets before I ran into
plan B stuff yep you know so like you
take plan B in stock to flow and you
take Maher multiple because Maher
multiple was very low it was it like 0.7
right when I when I bought these call
options and then ball was low so I'm not
paying very much for the volatility
premium I get a really long time premium
and then like I have a strike that's 1k
out of the money mm-hm
you know when which you know if you're
looking if you're at a point 7 May or
multiple you're at 4k and the 200 moving
average is that like 5500 and you're
kind of at the bottom of the bear market
you know cuz you've looked at like these
four year cycles another thing you're
like how much lower can this thing go
it's like probably not much over the
next 18 months especially the happening
thrown in there and so boom you know
bought those things yeah I mean I'll
probably who knows how much I'll make on
those things if we we have 55 K Bitcoin
oh holy cow that that at $1,500 premium
is gonna turn into like $50,000 yeah
it's right crazy yeah so let's talk a
little bit about the structural issues
in the legacy system right now obviously
you can get repo market we're recording
this right now while there was a
liquidity crisis driven by withdrawals I
think as the as the way that is being
described payments yeah yeah I think you
and I probably think of it differently
maybe just describe kind of your
assessment as to what's happened and
transpired how they're trying to fix it
and what the issues are with it yeah so
basically like Center your banking
banking system you got the neck.you yet
next day repos right like it's overnight
cash
and some some banks are paying 10%
interest for overnight cash like this is
this is crazy like why are you well
you're so leveraged and in such a bad
position that you got to pay ten percent
interest to like not go bankrupt I guess
or whatever and we don't have any
transparency into what's going on yeah
I'd sure like to know who it is
yeah so I can short him yeah and really
it's if you know that they're paying ten
percent on the on the money that they're
borrowing overnight you know that it's
got to be really really bad because
that's such an egregious interest rate
oh yeah I mean it's huge and it's like I
mean this is overnight money right and
so you know I think in and so it was
like 50 is like fifty three billion
dollars that the Fed stepped in to like
goose the system with it but that wasn't
know so it was the first yeah that's the
first one you got oversubscribed and
they're not cumulative because it's
overnight right but then the feds like
oh well we'll option seventy-five
billion and there was eighty billion
dollars a bit so five billion dollars of
shortfall didn't get funded yeah well
you're basically saying is so first day
fifty three billion second day seventy
five billion and then they find the next
day but on Wednesday the second day of
the facility or the overnight cash
basically there was eighty billion
dollars of need only 75 billion guns
under there and so that five billion
dollar Delta is not a good sign well
yeah that means somebody somebody needed
five billion dollars of overnight cash
and they get it and so what's the entire
Act is that well who is it like why
don't we start naming some names on who
didn't get there didn't get their bids
in the in the in the emergency why had a
credit basically from the Fed right and
so you know that the the implications of
this are look at toys-r-us you know
great example they they they were
hobbling along and then the creditors
yanked their line of credit and
immediately they're in they're in
bankruptcy you know that's what happens
like cash cash is king like you need
that liquidity safety and liquidity
right like II
and so you what's the number one killer
of
businesses the number one killer is
cashflow not necessarily that you have a
profitable or unprofitable businesses
that you miss masher mismatch your cash
flows and and you know when I did my
accounting degree my absolutely favorite
financial statement was the cash flow
statement you know because like that's
one you know is like where everything is
like tells you everything and how
healthy company is and you know how much
cash is it is it generating and able to
throw off and stuff like that or is it
using a bunch of it and so I think that
this is you know that what's happening
in the repo markets is just very you
know cuz what happens when the banks
don't have enough cash well they they
need to start cutting lines of credit so
that so that they can they can call that
cash in and so that's a source of cast
instead of the use of cash for them you
know so they start raining in on credit
that's been extended everybody and next
thing you know like the company that's
living paycheck to paycheck doesn't that
doesn't have a line of credit anymore
and they go into bankruptcy and and then
it starts getting fun because we have
counterparty risk counterparty risk
being that's where you're reliant on the
financial ability of the counterparty to
perform and so you know what happens
when you when you've written like a
massive derivative and the counterparty
fails
well now the I think it what is it the
the nominal becomes notional yeah which
and Warren Buffett described them as
financial weapons of mass destruction
and so that they start blowing holes in
people's balance sheets and and how are
the derivatives accounted for well to
get the bonuses you you undervalue the
liabilities and you over value the
assets you know so we have a mismatch in
the valuation of the derivatives on all
and on everybody's balance sheets also
so I think that might be playing a role
in this because it's like well I don't
want to win that Bank the five billion
dollars that they need because like I
don't trust how they're valuing their
assets what and I guess part of this is
people will say ok let's agree that
everything you're saying is correct in
the legacy financial system how does
Bitcoin fix this right that the kind of
one of these new memes is that there is
a plan B right
does fix this how do you think about
that either transition or that solution
entering a financial world well I mean
what's so beautiful about gold and
Bitcoin is that they are equity based
they are nobody's liability they are
sovereign well right so like you don't
you don't have to have a line of credit
with anybody you don't you completely
eliminate counterparty risk mm-hmm so
you know that's nice that XYZ bank needs
five billion dollars but I'm not gonna
give it to him mm-hmm
and I don't care if they fail mm-hmm let
them fail yep and and so now you know
for a whole for hot where's the Bitcoin
you know we we actually benefit from the
collapse of all of these institutions we
want them to fail we don't want them to
get bailed out yeah what do you think
about the ethical implications in terms
of the people who get hurt if that
happens well you know bitcoins been
around for a decade it's been on all the
major news stuff like what you do and
being greedy like trying to get a get a
higher return by having money in this
overall leverage bank the like why were
you doing that mm-hmm you know what why
didn't you put money in Bitcoin you know
so hey that's just how the system works
the people who calculate correctly
economically they have profits and games
and the people who calculate incorrectly
they have losses and the people on the
other side of this golf because there's
no way to avoid the final crack-up boom
there's gonna be a lot of collateral
damage
just don't be part of it and you know
the first rule of panic is to do it
first
you know the Andreas actually talked
about this when I brought up proof of
key she's like you know I'm actually
worried that it might actually be
successful and that people might
actually withdraw their bitcoins and
then we might actually have failures of
Bitcoin companies because you know they
don't have the bitcoins that they owe
everybody and I'm like what's wrong with
that I mean let's mark-to-market all
these losses why why are we extending
and pretending like you know I want to
know who's got what and who owns what I
mean I know what I own you know cuz it's
in my hot little hand you know prove the
keys like let's prove who's actually got
the assets and
and have the value you know so and and
describe what proof of keys is for those
that don't know yet so proof of keys
proof of keys com
it's an annual celebration January third
every year everybody withdraws all of
their bit coin and crypto from any third
party just prove the keys you're gonna
learn something yo cuz they're either
gonna send it to you or they're not and
if they don't send it to you I guess
what you just learned something yep you
learned that you you thought you had a
Bitcoin but you couldn't actually get it
in your hot little hand and you know
last year we we had a we had a casualty
quadriga CX announced proof of keys a
week later he met with his attorney to
set up a will week after that he died in
India you know a couple couple weeks
later approving keys a couple weeks
after that quadric ucx goes into
bankruptcy and we have a whole bunch of
people waiting in line thinking that
they might get 10 cents on the dollar if
they were Malcolm lucky right so like
you know but the moral implications you
know it's it's not the the people who
have the assets at these institutions
they're there's no moral wrongdoing on
their part saying give it to me the the
more wrongdoing is on the person who was
engaged in the fraud you know and said
that oh we've got 10 bitcoins when
really we only have eight yeah for sure
well and look you obviously have been
one of the early semesters in Bitcoin
you've been one of the most convicted
investors right and I think you've
publicly stated that you're continuing
to still acquire a Bitcoin today right
this is a thing where you made an early
investment and you know cross your
fingers hope it works out and go do
other things like you were still
actively buying derivatives you're
acquiring Bitcoin etc maybe talk a
little bit about your philosophy just
that as as someone who was early but but
still is very active and convicted yeah
so I mean that how do our last resort
and like what else are you gonna buy I
mean I don't want I don't want to buy a
real estate I mean they buy real estate
in Chicago like they're just gonna jack
up your property taxes guess what
there's there's no account fee for
holding Bitcoin negative interest rates
in Europe negative interest rates on
your bank account
don't get that on Bitcoin property taxes
going up don't get that on Bitcoin you
know company decided not to pay a
dividend not not getting cashflow don't
have that with bitcoins bitcoins safe
liquid you know and if Plan B's right
it's like going to the freaking moon
sooner than we might have thought and
and then you know trading the
derivatives on it you know bitcoins
highly volatile and so if you're gonna
be a hardware of last resort you're
gonna be exposed to all this volatility
why not get paid for it you know so like
I love selling these calls on ledger X
and then I turn around and I take the
premium from the calls and I sell puts
and I'm outside of these different may
or multiple bands and I'm like and I'm
in it I actually have a pretty complex
algorithm that like spits out you know
all this stuff using Plan B's and I'm
tinkering on it and stuff too but you
know at the end of the day like I'm able
to either require a lot more USD or I
end up acquiring Bitcoin because I sold
the puts
yep with the premium and so you know
this becomes a way you know and I'm
gonna be exposed to the to the
volatility anyways and a good example of
this is so when Bitcoin ran a few months
ago to 13,800 about 13,000 I sold a
bunch of August and September 20 and 25
K calls and we said it again I sold 20
and 25 K calls August and September okay
right when Bitcoin ran to 13 K uh-huh
like back in July so the price went up
so you had the Delta and then you had
the increase in the volatility and so I
got a lot more on the premium so I got
anywhere from 300 to 600 dollars premium
per Bitcoin with 20k strikes like only
two months out mm-hmm and then you know
Bitcoin the price came back down you
know to ten grand or whatever the
volatility retreated I closed a either
closed or had expired worthless all
those calls that I sold and I turn
around and written put like 99th and 10k
puts with Bitcoin so they just fight
you're playing a game where once you
understand the market
and kind of the volatility you're able
to play both sides of it and do it in a
pretty risk-adjusted way yeah and and
what's really cool about it is there's
plenty of opportunity here because some
people are measuring their portfolio in
USD some people are measuring their
portfolio in Bitcoin is some people are
kind of measuring it in both well you
know if you if you sell the covered call
at 13 K your your your collateral has to
get locked up so it's a risk right so it
goes from 13 K at a 10 K it the
collateral goes down 3,000 us and I only
have $500 of premium for accepting that
type of downside volatility right but as
a Bitcoin auteur I'm just fine with it
because I just want to hot on my Bitcoin
and not be taxing getting a recognition
event so also these long
out-of-the-money calls which if they get
exercise are gonna exercise it like a
2.6 plus mayor multiple so I'm kind of
fine selling it that higher mayor
multiple anyways and then turning around
and selling puts all the way down on the
USD in order to reacquire the Bitcoin
Hahnel stack got it
any crazy stories from the early days of
Bitcoin oh man there's like a unlimited
number of those things how about this
was fun one so I was helping Charlie
Shrem and Erik Voorhees plan the first
Bitcoin conference in San Jose in 2013
and I paid for a bunch of expenses and
stuff and so they were supposed to
reimburse me and if you ever try to get
Charlie Shrem to send you Bitcoin it
takes a little while he understands cash
is king right so eventually a to three
weeks later he finally sent the bitcoins
to me but I still have those been going
on and I think those things are like
they were there there are a couple
million bucks you know we're just
talking like de minimis incidental stuff
at the time thousand dollars of expenses
yeah so I mean it's just crazy like how
much fun it is to you know cuz like that
first conference been like all the Latin
American Bitcoin conferences investments
you know help seed fund cracking but I
mean I I looked at bitinstant
you know it's
we sure I'm staying past on that good
call yeah yeah yeah I was like charlie
you're either in confident with your
financials or you're engaged in fraud
either way I can't invest in you huh
yeah I don't want to pay for your
criminal defense attorney
which is exactly what ended up happening
right there is another another exchange
I looked at before crackin interviewing
the CTO who didn't I mean all the all
the hacker type questions just went
right over his head so pass on that one
they eventually brought on as their
chief compliance officer one of the
Rogues Silk Road agents the this is now
in jail so dodged a bullet there you
know so it's you know didn't just get
lucky you know you have to use some use
some brain power in this area but it's
it's been so much fun too because I mean
we're for changing the world I mean this
is monetary sovereignty that we're
bringing to people and and property
rights is really what lifts us out of
poverty so if you want to help change
the world and really help people who
have a better life and all that stuff I
mean you're not gonna find a more
powerful tool in my opinion than Bitcoin
to do that and so then it's just how do
you get involved with it I continue to
say that bitcoins rise to prominence and
success would likely do more for the
world in terms of equality and kind of
positive impact then all all
philanthropy combined simply because it
changes the structural issues that are
keeping 50 plus percent of the world's
population enslaved to debt enslaved to
inflation etc yeah you have you have
property rights coupled with eliminating
or getting rid of this economic
censorship this happened you know and
that that's the real problem we've got
you know we've entrepreneurs and people
in the developing countries and even in
the development and in the developed
countries they can't allocate capital in
in a wise way because there's been so
much economic censorship by the
institution of the state and bitcoin
helps just slice through all that and so
yeah I mean you're like you're doing
good for the world you're doing good for
yourself you know take care of yourself
Bitcoin helps you do that focus on your
health your wealth your relationships
your experiences in life like live a
good a good life you know Bitcoin helps
that - because you're shifting your time
preference and when when a lot of
individuals start shifting that the
culture begins to change and then you
know if we if we have a much longer time
preference in our culture you know we're
going to be tackling a lot of issues
like pollution and deforestation and
like all of these things that really
should be solved with property rights
yeah and we'll be able to do that and
guess who's gonna have the money it's
gonna be people who like had this change
in time preference for sure what's the
one thing that you look at moving
forward that would be the biggest most
important inflection point in bitcoins
adoption or success I think it's going
to be a lot of these large asset
managers realizing that they just have
to unpick coin mmm
and tenets it's a I mean it's gonna be
crazy like we've backed and ledger acts
and these options and having to hedge it
into your portfolio because once that
starts happening I mean we're talking
bitcoins like cryptos of two hundred
billion dollar market cap like that's
nothing yeah I mean we got companies
with more cash on their balance sheets
oda coins entire market cap yep and
there's always enough Bitcoin it's just
a matter of price you know so people are
gonna have to bid that price up and how
do you how do you bit the price up at a
have you get how do you get a hot
where's of last resort to be selling
Bitcoin and so this is a one by one
revolution in terms of claiming our
monetary sovereignty and and people get
to choose it you know this isn't
coercive in any way so if you haven't
chosen it you have no one to blame but
yourself I completely agree what's the
one thing that you think people
misunderstand about Bitcoin that you
want to correct I think they just
understand the economics they do not
understand to him nobody understands
Austrian economics those that do you
know might have a cursory skin deep
water waterskiing understanding of it
like Peter Schiff and then be be warping
it to serve their own self-interest
instead of the actual science of the
economics it's just a bunch of political
dogmatist and so I mean if people really
understood what the sound is hardest
money that the the the the human race is
invented really means and
terms of its implications I think you
know we'd have a radically different war
halt and change would be happening so
much faster and it's already happening
extremely fast I couldn't agree more
last question for you what's the most
important book you've ever read oh man
that's a great one
well it really depends on the topic you
know if you just look back at your life
you say the most important book on my
life that I've read is oh I mean I
really like Heaven and Hell by Emanuel
Swedenborg you know he was I ran into
him because he he was I mean massive
polymath came up with the atomic atomic
theory a grandfather of psychoanalysis
and he was master of the minds so he was
in charge of the mining industry in
Sweden he was in the Royal Court and he
took took time away from some of some of
his work in order to help fix Sweden's
monetary system and so I think that just
helps us understand just how important
how important the money really is and
fixing that you know cuz all the great
poly masks have been have thought about
this Isaac Newton Goethe Swedenborg our
NICUs Jefferson you know a lot of these
people and so you know I think I think
that's that's probably one of the books
because you know when you start shifting
time preference you know ultimately
you're gonna you're gonna get to the
question of like well what happens after
you die yeah and and that's where you
run into Swedenborg and so you know it's
interesting that he took time off from
that much more important thing because
running around collecting mário coins
like what difference is that gonna make
yeah yeah but but he he actually took
time away from from that much more
important work to focus on helping fix
the Swedish monetary system and all the
implications that would have for society
and you wrote it out in a paper and and
so you know I I find you know in terms
of most important books I mean there's
so many out there
human action there's money there in
state there's what's government's done
to our money you got a religious text
like across the board that help you like
live a better life
you've got Bitcoin standard I mean
they're they're just so many good books
that are attached like if you're working
on relationships you got flow if you're
trying to find happiness in life like
how what are the rules or principles for
that I mean there's so many like
phenomenal books that people can read
and you are kind of the sum total of the
ideas that you put into that like gray
matter in between your ears the the food
diet and the knowledge diet are both
important what uh working people find
you on the internet yeah so at trace
Mayer on Twitter not too active but but
I I stir stuff up now and then and then
Bitcoin knowledge podcast so W W Bitcoin
KN and thanks so much for having me
absolutely thank you so much for doing
this you're a legend hey everyone pop
here if you like this episode of off the
chain and want to help us take crypto to
the top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking fifteen seconds to fill
those stars in and leave a quick review
goes a long way and helping us take the
entire crypto ecosystem to the top of
the charts I appreciate you listening
and see you next time on off the chain
you